women are being warned not to put garlic
in their private parts yeah i've read
about to treat
yeast infections do you know that sal
had some sort of like because he's
uncircumcised he had yeast in his pouch
and he put garlic on his penis and it
and it got soared i'm not making a joke
and he really did it yeah like
i don't know where this garlic thing is
coming from but sal is even putting
garlic on his dick and he said it was
really nasty it couldn't get worse
yeah i mixed it with yogurt it said to
mix it with yogurt
and i chopped up the garlic and i
stuffed stuffed it in my pouch
and then the next morning i woke up it
was all red it was sore
it was out of control but like why don't
you just go to a doctor and have him
treat these things and i did eventually
up that i have uh what's it's called
balanitis which is like a male
version of a yeast infection i know
what's weird about you is like what was
that stuff you were taking
um recently for my cholesterol yet uh
red yeast rice yeah he took
red yeast rice for his cholesterol and
then of course when he finally went to a
doctor
his cholesterol level was even higher
than it was supposed to be yeah it was
like doubled
yeah so yeah i eventually went to a
doctor so yeah don't stick garlic on and
i made the mistake i
i was carrying this around in a canister
so
i didn't realize like you needed to
refrigerate the yogurt and the garlic oh
no
yeah so when i put it on my penis it was
actually out for about eight or nine
hours
oh my god so i i developed this new
bacteria on my [ __ ]
like why where do you learn these things
that garlic should go on you like where
do where do you pick up this information
you know what i i just i just google all
this stuff and then you know
but googling is not good i mean go to a
doctor yeah no [ __ ]
house [ __ ] is like a sandwich you know
when you go out in manhattan on the
street and you buy those what are those
gyro gyro your cock's like a gyro
sandwich
the ingredients of a gyro is there i
once want tea tree oil
for my [ __ ] no now that's got to burn
a [ __ ] i hit the roof what type
of oil tea tree oil
yeah and then robin there's another oil
i bought and why did you put that on
your [ __ ]
for the same thing i was experimenting
with my balonitis
i swear to god howard i bought this oil
it was it was purple and i just thought
okay it's just the color of it and my
dick was like purple for a month
[ __ ] off why would you not go to a
doctor he'll try
anything but a doctor why are people
anti-doctors all of a sudden
i'm really not i just figured that you
know i i'm into homeopathic stuff
no you're not but you at least go to a
homeopath you're doing it on your own
yeah you're trying to figure this stuff
out and
you're not that smart thank you robin i
mean yeah he's an idiot and i don't mean
that as a
knock i had a purple [ __ ] for a month i
guess you're right yeah